you know for all of the fear-mongering
about democrats
really being socialists obama was a
marxist
bernie is a communist all of this stuff
you've been seeing it for years
is it possible that donald trump is the
most
socialist president that we've ever had
or at least
in decades you know we did a story a
year or two ago
about is donald trump the first atheist
president we talked about other
non-religious presidents or
presidents believed to be non-religious
and
we talked about the reality that donald
trump appears to be lying about being
religious
just to try to placate evangelical
voters
it doesn't make trump a better president
not to be religious but he just might
not be
religious despite his claims that he
loves the bible and all of this stuff
well what about trump as a socialist
president now to be clear
trump is not a socialist but we are
talking here about
the the sort of haphazard definition of
socialism and communism
that the right likes to wrongly ascribe
to the ideas of the left
but there is a long list of the
socialization of some elements of the
economy by donald trump
that could arguably make trump the
closest thing we've had
to the definition of a socialist
president that his
supporters tend to ascribe to socialism
now
you know to be clear there's socialism
and then there's sort of like social
democracy that is sometimes called
socialism
i understand that but let's consider
this and use the spectrum because that's
really what it is
in terms of government stimulus which
the right
loves to call socialism the first
coronavirus relief package was 2.2
trillion in the cares act
trillions coming in additional forms
trillions pumped into the market by the
fed
this is way way way bigger than the
obama stimulus which
they called socialist remember obama was
a socialist for an 800 billion dollar
stimulus bill
and for mandating you buy private health
insurance
from for-profit companies bush's bank
bailout
was about 400 billion this is like 8
trillion in total
trump used the defense production act to
force general motors to make ventilators
after initial talks broke down over
costs
this is heavy government involvement in
directing the activities
of private industry something that the
right loves to call
socialism in soviet russia the
government tells you
what kind of bread to make trump
threatened to condition the sale of
tick-tock to microsoft
on the u.s receiving a very big
portion of the sale price and said that
nobody else thinks about deals this way
other than him
straight up saying government will take
a cut
of a private business deal because why
because trump wants a cut
if barack obama had ever suggested
anything like this fox news would have
gone bananas for 10 days
donald trump has massively expanded
direct farm aid from 11 billion in 2017
to more than 32 billion in 2020 all so
he could
pay off the farmers who were hurt by his
trade war he has
socialized a larger portion of
agriculture
than previous presidents when harley
davidson wanted to move some of its
manufacturing over to europe
trump threatened them with regulating
them and taxing them like never before
this is extraordinarily heavy-handed in
terms of a government crackdown on a
business
that the right calls socialists when a
democrat suggests
doing it trump moved to prop up the
local
the uh domestic coal industry
despite the market deciding it's time to
wrap up coal coal doesn't make sense
the government is overriding markets
to decide which industry will succeed or
fail
wow and where is the right on this trump
has also
raised the deficit massively obama left
office
with about a 500 billion deficit
down from 1.5 trillion remember that
deficit not debt
trump doubled where barack obama left
off before coronavirus
and now obviously with coronavirus
everything is completely out of control
the right loves to say those socialist
democrats raise the deficit but it's
trump who's done it historically
trump when asked about debt and deficit
deflects and talks about you know we've
got to build up the military and the
wall
and that's going to help the overall
economy
which is almost like a modern monetary
theory type
argument which is just do the projects
and the economy will benefit except
trump's doing it with the wrong projects
that would make sense to say
you know improving health care and
education in the short run might
increase the deficit
but we will benefit so much that in the
long run it will actually be
deficit negative or deficit neutral
trump's sort of making that argument
but with the wrong things like building
a wall as an example
now trump supporters will say trump
didn't want to do any socialism
but he had to do it because of
coronavirus for the good of the country
and that's true to us
to a certain degree but it's what he did
nonetheless
a true capitalist would have said let
the businesses fail
if you don't want to fly because of a
virus let the airlines go under that's
not what donald trump is doing
it's also the experience of fdr by the
way
i mean he arguably
somewhat reluctantly came to some of the
policies he came to
in order to kind of save capitalism from
itself now
fdr is seen by some as the most
socialist president we've had trump has
arguably done
more presidents have to respond to the
events of their presidency that's for
sure you can't remove coronavirus from
it
sort of like imagining lincoln's
presidency without the civil war
or fdr's presidency without recovering
from the great depression in world war
ii
trump had to deal with coronavirus but
he chose to do it this way it could have
been done other ways
now of course trump has also done other
things that are not
socialistic right he's deregulated
business so business can pollute more
so cars can be less efficient cut
funding to agencies cut
taxes for some people but despite all of
that by many measures
trump could still be the most
socialistic president
in many of our lifetimes you've got to
go back at least to nixon
who created the epa osha boosted
regulation
social security benefits maybe you'd go
back to dwight eisenhower who passed the
interstate highway act
subsidized mortgages and college tuition
had a 91 percent top marginal tax rate
despite
lots of ways to reduce the effective tax
rate what's the reaction from trumpists
absolutely none they're too busy trying
to suppress the vote to actually care
about what it is that donald trump is
doing
weird times we live in my friends